this is a production of Cornell
University
okay great thanks so it's great to be
here today
once again I'm Troy building professors
visiting associate professor in Matt's
laboratory from Brazil okay so today I'm
going to talk about here my topics and
objectives I'm going to talk about a
little bit about agriculture in Brazil
and also in the Amazon I'm going to get
into a little bit about cover crops the
actual situation right now and then the
need for cover crops in agricultural
systems in the Amazon
I'll talk about approve an analysis of
pyramidal and meta-analysis rather that
I did just finished the first draft on
the use of pearl millet in the
agricultural systems in the Amazon then
I'll get into some present in future
work in Brazil that that we're doing
then we'll have the closing comments
so probably as many of you know
Brazil's an agricultural leader in the
world they the country was a net
importer of food grains in the 70s and
it was considered to be sort of backward
in terms of Agriculture whereas now
today it's a powerhouse agribusiness I
think in 2017 was responsible for around
40% of exports and maybe a third of GDP
and every year a large percentage of
growth in GDP comes from agribusiness in
Brazil if we look at this figure here we
can see that for a lot of the
commodities the rank and world
production value increased during the
period from 1970 to 2017 increased quite
a bit especially for chicken for meat
from cattle soybeans Brazil is one of
the world largest exporters and all
these products probably the larger
producer and exporter of oranges coffee
so it is a world leader production and
total factor productivity has more than
doubled during this period and part of
that is due to the increase in area of
especially soybeans during the period
from 1970 to 2017 area of soybeans
increased 70% and corn increased by 30
percent
Brazil is also a world leader in no-till
agriculture we can see here that here we
go the area under no-till in 2007-2008
was about 25 to 1/2 million hectares
it's about 65 million acres and there
was a 20% increase during about the last
10 years and today they have about 81
million acres under no-till about 70% of
all cultivated land in Brazil is under
no-till agriculture so that's really
something that Brazilian farmers are
sold on they really believe that no-till
is one of the foundations to make
agriculture sustainable so now I want to
explain a little bit about how things
have changed in recent years the first
of all the savanna or saddle in
Portuguese biome or ecosystem is where a
lot of this increase in agriculture has
occurred in Brazil and still is
increasing it's a huge area larger than
California and Alaska combined we can
see the image here that's in green
that's the saddle a half of it is de
forested and there was a large increase
in agricultural land use between 2000
and 2014 so so what has happened is that
farmers have basically migrated from the
south of Brazil up through the cerrado
and now during the last 10 maybe 15
years farmers have migrated into the
Amazon to where I'm located and that's
considered to be one of the agricultural
frontiers in Brazil today so capitalized
farmers are making this migration today
due to there's a lot of factors involved
but basically it has to do with cheaper
land
so the geographic area of the focus of
my talk of a lot of things I'm going to
talk about today is Western para so if
we look here this is the legal Amazon
okay and then the state of Para is here
I'm located right about here in this
region that's the top of Joyce River at
the confluence of the Amazon River and
then these areas in red show basically
the region that I'm referring to you as
Western pada which is more or less this
region here okay so what's the most
important on a large scale at least
agricultural activity in this region of
the Amazon its soybeans followed by corn
okay what happens is that soybeans are
planted sometime usually around the end
of December beginning of January it
depends on the year the climate and then
they're harvested sometime around the
end of April mid May something like that
after the harvest corn is planted it's
called the second crop corn
Selenia in portuguese and this allows
farmers to to harvest two crops on the
same piece of land during one season
okay so that's planted immediately after
the soybeans are harvested so if the
soybeans are harvested at the beginning
of May just a couple days after so the
corn is planted and then it's harvested
sometime around the end of August the
beginning of September okay so farmers
can get to crops
so then looking at these dates you know
these periods of time these months the
question is what about August September
through December January what about that
more or less four months period what
happens then and that's what I'm gonna
talk about a little bit today here I
wanted to put into context the
importance of agriculture to the economy
in this region of the Amazon we can see
here some statistics on the production
chain of soybeans and corn in this
region this industry is responsible for
about 5,000 direct indirect jobs there
are about 240,000 acres of soybeans and
corn planted every year in the region
and that's responsible for about sixty
million dollars each year in financial
transactions so this puts into context
the magnitude of what's going on in this
agriculture land use change here's some
figures from PhD student with whom I
worked we can see here as a dynamics of
land-use change in the region we've got
three of the most important
municipalities in the region mazui Delta
and synthetic and the land-use change
from 2001 to 2014 and as you'll see
land-use change the direction of things
is very different in each place for
example 61% during the period 61 percent
of land use change was forest and
pasture to agriculture in mazui here in
Belle Terre 90% or more was forced in
agriculture going to pasture and then in
santorini 84 percent was forest that got
converted to agriculture and pasture so
I think one of the reasons for this is
it has to do with prices for commodities
on international national and
international markets and farmers have
the flexibility to year-to-year they can
turn a pasture into a soy field or vice
versa
a lot of times what will happen is if
soit prices go up a farmer will rent out
his land for two or three years to a
neighboring farmer that has the capacity
the equipment and knowledge and
everything to grow soybeans so that's an
interesting dynamic in the region so
let's get into a little bit about cover
crops here now one of the things that's
been going on in the last few years
there is interceding of Congo grass as a
cover crop mulch for no-till planting so
here we've got images from December of
this year of 2018 sorry showing the
dried Congo grass just before soybean
planting and what happens is that this
grass is interceded it's it's either
interceded within the Rose soybean just
a few weeks before harvest or it's
interceded into the second crop corn
when the corn gets to be maybe about 15
centimeters or so the advantages of the
congo grass are that it has a rapid
establishment that it has a high
sensitivity to desiccation which is
really good for a no-till mulch and the
cattle can be grazed on it so after
harvesting a second crop corn you can
bring cattle in there the the harvesting
when you harvest the second crop corn
the grass will shoot right up the cattle
can come in graze on that and also on
the corn residuals some of the
disadvantages of the the use of Congo
grass are that it has a high
susceptibility to pests cigogne is the
name I think spittlebug here and has low
drought resistance and that's something
I'm going to talk about just in another
slide coming right up so here's an image
of no-till planting in January this year
that's the Congo grass mulch with the
soybean being planted in and then this
is about a month later you can see the
mulch on the ground here with soybeans
growing quite well and in the background
that's a
Castaneda that's a Brazil nut tree so
what you'll see down there is are these
huge fields that go out sometimes
through the horizon and they'll be
interspersed with these lone huge trees
sitting all by themselves Brazil nut
tree because you can't cut them down so
it's a kind of a neat thing to see it
makes for an interesting visual so here
we are with soybeans about two months
after planting the end of March of this
year growing quite well
very vigorous and and looking at the
this image here it makes you sort of
think that well the Congo grass really
serves as a cover crop it's doing its
job and that may be the case but the
thing is that these guys these farmers
these guys are planting this Congo grass
based on what happens in mato grosso in
in the sahara so it's sort of empirical
there's no experimental basis for this
just yet so that leads me naturally to
conclude that there are lots of unknowns
therefore a great need for
diversification of cover crops in the
region for example farms with little
farms with no cattle don't need to use
pasture grass as cover then the other
thing I thought about is does this Congo
grass as it really does it make
sufficient mulch biomass mulch for the
no-till crop what what are the effects
of it on cash crop yield does it
contribute to the yield of the cash crop
pest resistance potential for
intercropping
other uses such as seeds and can we use
this for as a seed bank and then what
about drought tolerance and and in our
region
that's a big deal and I'm gonna explain
that here now so climate and water
balance are going to be really important
in terms of decision making about what
cover crops we're gonna use you can see
here you've got an image of the
Brazilian Amazon with the köppen
classification coloured in this is from
a publication of colleagues of mine from
Umbra
here's pata and the arrow arrow points
to where I'm located so our region is a
mix of a m3 and a m4 so that means we
get a pretty strong dry season in this
region and we can see here looking at
the water balance figure that I made
here from 1990 to 2000 18 millimeters of
rainfall an average temperature here the
line is the average temperature so the
blue is a rainfall the green is the
excess and then the red is the deficit
that exists and if you look at the
figure you can see the deficit available
water deficit begins sometime around the
end of July it's really strong for a
couple of months and then begins to
diminish towards the end of December so
this period is a really important moment
in terms of the agricultural year the
agricultural cycle and this is sort of
what I'm going to talk about in terms of
cover crops here there's another factor
here yeah that's really important to
take into account and besides our
natural seasonal variation we're having
problems with droughts in the region
we've had droughts 2005 15 10 and 15
pretty severe droughts that appear to
get longer and duration and more severe
so these figures from 2018 publication
here show monthly precipitation well let
me first explain here the dashed line is
the 16 year average from 2000 to 2016
the solid line is what happened in 2015
and 16 so we've got monthly
precipitation here by satellite and by
rain gauges and both show a decrease of
16 17 percent in rainfall during the
period 2015-2016 and the gauges showed a
decrease of 16 percent compared to the
hundred and 15 year average so this is a
big deal actually during
December January February of 2015 16
pastors caught on fire roadsides were on
fire Forest caught fire cattle are
breaking down barbed wire fences to get
into greener pastures
so this is real we're seeing this down
there here we have temperature it was a
point seven degrees Celsius above the 16
year average vapor pressure deficit same
thing higher and then the maximum
climatological water deficit shows a
very large deficit that basically
continued all the way through this whole
period so in other words when the rains
came finally there was still a large
deficit because it was the the deficit
was so strong in the previous months so
seeing this and thinking about this made
me think you know that this is this
shows that there's a great need for
incorporation of drought resistant cover
crops during the follow period between
cultivation of cash crops
here's an image of the drought with so
we can see this this demonstrates
clearly what happened the due to the
drought planting of soybeans were
delayed three months or so we can see
here at the end of May 2015 we were
doing a soil sampling on this day and
soybeans were harvested and then we can
see here about a year later May 12 2016
sly beans were basically just planted so
due to the drought everything got
delayed and what ended up happening is
that the second crop corn wasn't planted
that year so what does that mean that
means that farmers lost out economically
they didn't plant they didn't harvest
not just that there's an opportunity
cost involved meaning that farmers left
fields bare during a dry season when
they could have gone in there and
planted some kind of cover crop that
would have enhanced soil fertility and
brought other benefits they didn't do it
because of the drought so everything
just laid bare so that's one of the
concrete effects that you can see right
here due to droughts in the region so
then the strong dry season and the
question of droughts requires the use of
a drought resistant cover crop and if we
look at the figure again a water balance
figure here millimeters of rainfall
temperature we've got a rainfall excess
and deficit here so soybeans are planted
somewhere around the end of December and
a normal year harvest occurs sometime in
April mid April so soon afterwards the
second crop is planted and then the
second crop is harvested sometime
generally in August ok and that gives us
this period here what I call the window
of opportunity when a drought resistant
cover crop could be introduced to
improve soil fertility and generate
mulch from no-till so I've got this
period here
and we have to also take into account
climate models climate models
demonstrate generally that droughts will
become more frequent rainfall will
become more intense during the wet
season and they'll be longer periods dry
periods with no rain so taking all this
as a whole thinking about it what might
be inadequate species of cover crop to
put in in this period here first of all
want to say that in the use of cover
crops in general across the Amazon is
sort of insipid
still um it hasn't really taken hold
just yet an example this is this map
from Kona B which is an agency that is
responsible for generating statistics
and data about agricultural production
in the country this is from July 18 and
it's for sorghum so we can see here in
the great majority of the Amazon region
there's nothing nothing for sorghum
the thing is though um I know for a fact
personally that there is sort of
implanting in the Amazon in our region
I've seen it know the farmers and I
talked to the president from the rural
syndicate in January and he said he
knows the farmers he knows the farms he
said yeah there's sorghum here there
might be a thousand hectares but there
saw them so on a macro scale you won't
see this I'm more local scale you'll
find the use of cover crops so then back
in the fall I started thinking about
what it is I wanted to do in terms of
writing and researching something and of
course I had an idea well you know I
look at about 50 species of cover crops
and write about them and their potential
for use in the Amazon and that became
became pretty evident very soon that I
couldn't do that
once I started to narrow down my focus
and really think about what it is I
wanted to say it became obvious that
even writing about maybe three or four
species would be tough but at any rate
some of the species I found here are
still Sciences they call it steel in
Brazil I think it might be called pencil
here wrote ilaria that's what they call
it there think about four species that
are used in Brazil sunhemp is what I've
seen their sorghum
Jack being a couple of different pasture
grasses and then pearl millet so
realizing that I could only use just one
species for this for this analysis I did
I opted to use pearl millet and the
title of the paper the first draft here
is the use of perilla as a cover crop
species in Amazonian agar ecosystems to
promote sustainable agriculture a
descriptive meta-analysis so then Y P
Glaucon basically because it appears to
have characteristics that make it
suitable for use in these systems down
Amazon and some of these characteristics
are that it's drought resistant
deep-rooted it's a c4 plant so they
adapted to tropical biomes systems it's
capable of a large biomass production
which is important for no-till it's a
nutrient recycler it can be used as a
grain or forage crop seeds are
relatively cheap and easily available
and also because I personally know that
this is being used in the region in the
Amazon - I've seen it there there might
be a thousand hectares of it once again
maybe less so
what are the what are the aspects of
them that I decided to look at in terms
of the use of Perelman as a cover crop
well they're a bunch of them here I'm
gonna just focus on these four and bold
the potential for biomass generation
residue decomposition nutrient cycling
and the effect on the cash crop yield
and I also looked at some others soil C
inputs percentage of soil coverage and
weed control potential as a forage cache
or seek robbery and drug resistance so
the overarching question here is what
are the possible contributions to the
resilience and the sustainability in
Amazonian agro ecosystems okay and
you'll see that I call this a meta
analysis a descriptive meta analysis for
those of you who are familiar with meta
analyses you probably know that you have
to have a series of standard things like
risk of bias assessment analysis of
variation among the studies that you use
probably some statistical analyses to
predict things I didn't do any of that I
just gathered all the studies I could
find that fit my criteria which I'm
going to show all the studies I could
find and then just reported averages
made averages and reported variation
associated with those averages and I did
a few simple statistical test two T
tests so as far as the meta-analysis
goals study inclusion criteria that's
one of the basic things so what am i
criteria first of all the study had to
be conducted in the sahaba
or the Amazon biome had to be done on an
axis all soil and it had to be done in
the field with no irrigation so those
are the basic criteria that I used to
include exclude studies since I found
very few studies done in the Amazon I
think I found three I used studies done
on off soft soils in the Sahara as a
proxy for conditions in the Amazon and
that's really not that big
stretch think about because both seasons
have a really strong both biomes have a
really strong dry season during
basically the same months and they are a
lot of oxisols they're a lot of the
agriculture is done on oxisols so let's
quickly look at some data here dry
biomass generation kilograms per hectare
here permanently
announcer Sol's in Brazil and the
studies I found were all between 95 and
2018 so the number of studies here
looking at Brazil as a whole without
regard to soil type biome or anything
found 78 studies and the end here is
larger than the studies because some
studies had values for these parameters
biomass here for example they had
several values from different sites or
different years so I just included them
as a sample found three studies for the
Amazon and 43 for the Cercado so these
values put it into context in the
literature what's established in the
literature is six mega grams here
that's just 6,000 kilograms per hectare
as being necessary to establish notail
in Brazil so then our values here for
the Sahara are well above that and for
the Amazon it approaches six so it's
only have three studies you have to take
that as a grain of salt with a grain of
salt but over half of the studies that I
found for the dry biomass were greater
than six for this are hotter than the
Amazon so that shows that pearl millet
has the potential to create what can be
considered sufficient dry biomass on
these oxisols soils and seasonally dry
ecosystems
so then nutrients here we're looking at
nutrients in the biomass the dry biomass
so here we have nutrient content at 0 60
and 120 days
after desiccation and this is for
Primula that was grown for sixty days
and also grown for 180 days and so we
got two different periods for which it
was grown and what we see here kilograms
per hectare is that basically for
permanently grown for sixty days
nitrogen potassium phosphorus and
potassium are greater then for her
mother grown for 180 days so there's
more nutrients in these plants when
they're desiccated basically at
flowering then if you let them mature
and set the seed so that's an
interesting result that'll explain a
little more that has implications for
management of pearl millet in these
systems so then what about release of
the nutrient so it's in the biomass what
about release well here we can see that
the release of NPK by pearl millet
biomass can be equal to the nutrients
that are exported in the cash crop so
looking here at soybeans and corn the
amounts of nutrients exported in four
and six mega grams of these on oxisols
oils in the sahaba
here we can see the nutrient content
that's released after 60 days of
decomposition so that's the end of these
orange bars and seeing these data from
the studies i gathered we can see that
pearl millet has the potential after 60
days of decomposition to replace
nutrients that are exported in soybeans
and corn so that's a pretty positive
result then the half-life of biomass the
studies had an average biomass of 36 for
the CN ratio so that shows that it's
probably a slower as far as the
decomposition goes half-life is about
109 days and then nutrients and
more or less than 60 here 60 days the
red line nutrients are all pretty much
near 50% or more here so that's a pretty
good result if after 60 days of
decomposition there's still a lot of
nutrients left in the biomass and
there's also a lot that's released to
the soil that's a good result for
nutrient cycling
so then what about transfer then to the
soil the enrichment of the soil by the
pearl millet biomass so here we have
studies that had data for up to 20
centimeters for nutrients transferred
after 60 days of decomposition and I had
studies well these are the studies I
found this is the perilla and the
control there were no
sickled difference in the t-test I did
here but what we can see is that Perla
is able to transfer large amounts of
nutrients to the soil and when we think
about cultivation intensive cultivation
on oxisols low fertility oxisols
this is important result because
stainability sustainability of
agricultural activities on these soils
is going to partially be related to be a
function of rather the ability of plant
species to absorb and efficiently
release nutrients in labile forms so
that's an interesting result and then
more specifically looking at the
phosphorus is transferred to the soil
here we've got a table now phosphorus
availability for soils of the state of
pata this is for umber appa
this shows the percent clay and then the
soil texture clay - sandy and here we
have low - very high concentrations of
phosphorus in the soil so remembering
that the average pea content transferred
to the soil from pearl millet was about
73 milligrams per decimeter cubed this
looking at the table we can we can see
that pearl millet has the potential to
raise pea levels to very high levels so
that could in theory reduce the need for
the use of phosphor fertile phosphorus
fertilizer
and it's important to remember that
oxisols are the soil order it is the
soil order that has the highest capacity
for fixation of phosphorus and in the
Amazon thirty-four percent of the soils
are oxisols and in my region they're
more highly concentrated a little bit
north and then south of the Amazon River
in my region Western paadhai there's a
huge percentage of oxisols in that
region so this is an important result
there's one caveat though and that is
that these data 73 here for phosphorus
these data don't tell us anything about
the way that parameter accesses
phosphorus in the soil if it's able to
access sources of phosphorus that are
considered moderately label and then
leave them in more labelled forms and
which is really important for phosphorus
cycling so that brings up a research
question which is basically how can we
approve the availability of phosphorus
and these are egg recalled chiral soils
okay the question is other plants such
as perma the pearl millet that can mine
phosphorus access forms that are
moderately labile associated with iron
and aluminum in soil and then release it
in labile forms one mechanism would be
the release of organic acid anions by
the roots into the rice rhizosphere
which would then compete for P
absorption sites so that's an
interesting research question and those
data that that I gathered from the
studies don't tell us anything about
that
the idea would be to cultivate plants in
controlled experiments and then do a
sequential fractionation to try to
extract different fractions of soil
phosphorus and that would help us to
understand the capacity for Puma in this
case to effect changes in the sources
and reserves of phosphorus in the soil
okay so last data slide here what are
the effects of pearl millet on cash crop
yield okay here we have kilograms per
hectare and I found Studies on rice
soybeans and corn my sample size is here
I didn't find any statistical
differences with the simple t-tests
individual studies do show that there
are effects actually especially for rice
pearl millet does have an effect on
yields specifically associated with the
input recycling rather of phosphorus and
potassium into the soils through the
biomass however a bunch of studies I saw
that I reported and show that this
effect of increase of cash crop yield is
only possible with an input of inorganic
nitrogen fertilizer and one of the ways
around that that I saw him in these
studies that I I gathered was the
question of intercropping intercropping
of pearl millet with species of croak
alladia sunhemp
and basically all the studies I saw on
the Oxus halls in sahaba this
intercropping resulted in higher yields
higher soil fertility higher yields of
the cash crop - and that's because of
the interaction between the N fixer the
sunhemp and the other benefits so that's
a pretty interesting result to the
question of intercropping
so to summarize some of this here they
eject the objective of the incorporation
of a cover crop by a farmer
to determine in this case how permanent
it would be managed in these systems for
example if the objective is just to
create biomass for mulch they can just
leave it basically 130 days or so is its
cycle you can leave it to grow as it
grows and matures even more it'll have a
higher leading concentration which could
be good for up for the biomass mulch now
remembering our available water balance
figure here with the different periods
of planting and harvest of soybeans and
second crop we have the question here
that if the objective is not just
biomass generation but nutrient cycling
then the idea would be try to
synchronize the planting of pearl millet
to maximize not just biomass but
nutrient transfer and from the data that
I was able to gather that looks to be
about 60 days of growth and 60 for
decomposition which fits nicely into
this period here of the dry season and
the four months window during the dry
season okay so now transitioning to some
present and future work in Brazil first
of all here's a map showing once again
the legal amazon with basically what i'm
located right there what we have is a
we've got a 30 hectare plot of land say
degraded pasture it's on a farm called
agua and what we want to do is create
sort of a model farm a demonstration
farm and an Agricultural Experiment
Research Station on this farm the owner
of this farm is a large animal
veterinarian
he's friend of mine he's a university
professor with me also and he
specializes in in bovine reproduction
and what he wants to do is create an
intensive cattle ranching system where
you've got rotations between pastures
and crops
you incorporate trees into the pastures
in the crops that's the integration
crops livestock and forest which is a
big deal
right now down in Brazil slowly taking
on in the Amazon region so this is our
plot of land here degraded master the
farmer is totally sold on the idea of
creating this project this model farm
and he's actually financed a good part
of the work we've been doing for the
last few years so this is a really great
opportunity for us
the idea would be to create sort of a
system like this which exists in
prodigal Mina's which is a region far
away in the state in the eastern part of
the state so you've got trees here
planted in rows with crops between the
trees and pastures with trees also and
then over time you rotate all of this
here's an example of soybeans with
eucalyptus trees planted in the middle
our idea is actually to see if we can't
plant on the topography following the
contour lines in that 30 hectare plot of
land that I showed that's uh this is a
an image from master student of mine
generated this image so that's our idea
is to do things a little bit differently
but the general idea is this is to
create an integrated system where you
have crops and pastures being rotated
when you use cover crops and also you
can do experiments in these these plots
another experiment that was just started
this year is attempting to say something
about the contribution of no-till
agriculture compared to conventional
agriculture in the Amazon so how does
that affect sustainability and the idea
so we have fields where no-till
agriculture soybeans planted right next
to conventionally planted soybeans and
that's replicated on five farms with the
same soil type and site history
basically and then we're gonna look at
crop productivity soil productivity and
microclimate parameters to try to say
something about no-till and Amazonian
Agrico systems soil fertility sampling
we did an intensive campaign of two
years of soil sampling in different
sites five different sites here in the
region integrated no-till crop pasture
rotation integrated no-till pasture
forests a managed pasture a degraded
pasture and the native forest control
so two years of data three seasons
within each year wet/dry and transition
and 720 total samples so just to show
some quick photos here the this is the
no-till corn soybean pasture site this
is managed pasture here's the
integration of crops livestock and
forest that forest is uh noble species
of wood mahogany Brazilian teak and a
bunch of others can't remember now
degraded pasture and then primary forest
so I just wanted to just include the
assist to show some of the things we've
been doing two years of data here three
different depths pH and the manage sites
gone up compared to the native forests
and then potential acidity here it's
gone down in comparison to the native
forests so in terms of availability of
nutrients nutrient cycling that's a
positive result
same thing for cation exchange capacity
and bass saturation here we can see our
sites in the manage sites basically
cation exchange has gone up compared to
the forest and also base separation so
once again in terms of nutrient cycling
we can consider that a pot as a positive
result
more specifically now looking at
available soil phosphorus what we have
here in the manage sites no-till crop
pasture and the crop livestock forest we
have two years of data showing there's
more available phosphorus in these sites
20 meters in the soil compared to the
other sites so that's a really
interesting result when you think about
the problems with phosphorus
availability in the soil and also the
question of phosphorus a more
geopolitical question of phosphorus
reserves in the world and that will only
get more difficult for Brazil as time
goes of course
so concluding here I have no idea about
time is that clock right yeah okay and
wanted to talk about a little bit about
expansion here and knowledge flows
amongst farmers we do a group together
with people from a brothel which are
part of our group we do these sort of
workshops where we'll get out and talk
to farmers this is something I've seen
here at Cornell and Matt Ryan's lab that
apparently they do really well
get together with farmers in the field
talk about their work
show recent research results bring them
here even and I think that's really
important to do and a little bit of done
of this there has shown me that there
are a lot of benefits to knowing what it
is that the people that are on the
frontline think what is their perception
in this particular workshop we wanted to
know what they thought were their
barriers to sustainable agricultural
activities what are the barriers
preventing them from planting trees and
building a nursery and engaging in some
of these activities on their on their
lands so we send out an invitation
doesn't appear too well here and we got
a really good response we talked with
about 20 soy bean corn farmers and
cattle ranchers some images here from
them from the event the way it works is
that will each member of our group will
give a five-minute maybe 10 minute
presentation on something that we're
working on and then we'll get together
with the farmers and sort of like a
brainstorming session where they'll
write down on small pieces of paper what
they think are barriers and then we'll
come up to the front of the room and put
them on the board and tally everything
up and what we end up creating is like
sort of a mental map of what this group
thinks our barriers and in this case
here the most important of these factors
here and the spyder plot was a lack of
land title um probably isn't a big
problem here but in the brazilian amazon
it's a huge problem a lot of farmers
don't have title to the land so if you
don't have title
you really can't do a whole lot in terms
of getting credit from a bank to do some
of these incorporate some of these
sustainable activities on your property
so they know about a lot of this stuff
and they want to do it but without land
title it really makes things very
difficult for them so that was one of
the most important things the other was
the lack of technical assistance in the
region all the farmers basically said
that there's a big lack of of people
that are qualified to guide them through
these sort of processes and techniques
and things so what they end up doing is
is within their community
they end up looking to one person who
they perceive as being like the best of
them
you know they look up to this person and
in the case of this group there is a
farmer that they all mentioned that I
know personally this farmer they say
well that guy you know he reads he
studies he knows the literature and he's
he's able to incorporate new techniques
into his system so he does it they'll
look up to him they'll actually consult
with him and maybe follow his lead even
and so for us as a research group that's
really important to know because if you
if you can maintain the communication
line open with that one farmer who's
perceived to be you know the best then
you can that's sort of a conduit to be
able to get to the rest of the farmers
so that was an interesting result for me
participating in these workshops so to
summarize here then final comments I
mentioned that there was about a four
month window
dry season where we can incorporate a
drought resistant cover crop to improve
soil fertility generate biomass for
no-till pearl millet may be able to fit
this niche because it's able to generate
sufficient dry biomass and and also the
question of sixty days of growth and 60
days of decomposition to liberate
nutrients if it's managed that way it
could fit the niche
the dry biomass values for no-till
combining those from the Amazon and the
Serrano we got a little more than six
mega grams per hectare the literature
says six is sufficient to establish
no-till in Brazil but I question that I
put right here why this value the
citation that I saw everywhere that
everybody uses this from 2001 but I
didn't never saw anything about why six
mega grams was was established as the
correct value so that would need to be
tested also the idea would be to get out
into the Amazon in general two different
farms and document the use of cover
crops in the region that would involve a
lot of traveling that kind of thing
also test several types of cover crops
and controlled field experiments the
question of phosphorus cycling the the
ability to access moderate labile
reserves in soil and make them labile
this transformation phosphorus is very
interesting that should be investigated
for pearl millet and then the model
experimental farm that's going to be
something that's going to allow us to
engage with farmers over time to show
them what we're up to maybe show some
new ideas and technologies and find out
you know what their perceived
difficulties are okay acknowledgments so
I'd like to acknowledge copies it's a
agency that's part of the Ministry of
Education in Brazil they funded my
proposal to come here and stay for a
year on a sort of sabbatical I suppose
it is so thank you very much copies the
Cornell librarians when I started this
work when I my first idea was do this
grant was it systematic review sort of
thing I went to the man library and I
settle out with the Cornell librarians
and talked with them great group of
people really knowledgeable they they
really sat with me helped me out quite a
bit
showed me all the great resource that
the library has so thank you Cornell
librarians Matt Ryan and the SCL I have
to say thank you very much
he's welcomed me with open arms since
I've been here I've learned a lot with
them even though we're from different
areas it doesn't matter we're all here
to learn I suppose so you know I thank
them Matt especially very much and then
of course finally family mmm sorry can't
forget the family all of us it's the
most important thing my family has been
very patient with me they've come to a
new place a new culture learn a new
language and accepted the challenge 100%
and I've been behind me the whole time
that I've been here working been in
library preparing this talk the paper
and everything so uh we all can't forget
our family thank you very much yeah I
think so I don't know please oh jeez
yeah um well there is a process thing is
it cost money so a lot of people don't
do it first of all it can be complicated
like a lot of things in Brazil I think
as long as there's no big conflict like
between two people who say they're the
owner of the land you can get it it just
takes a certain amount of resources and
money to do it and then that's not even
the biggest issue with the farmers they
want to know what the benefits will be
if they if they get land title and after
they get it they'll have to be
registered into the there's a registry I
can't remember the name right now but
it's a national registry and then
they'll have an obligation to do a whole
bunch of things with their land geo
referencing and report to the government
they'll be monitored and his side of
things so a lot of the landowners just
say to heck with it so it's not that
they can't do it like I said if as long
as there's no there's no conflict
between different landowners they're
open to do the process
it's just that sometimes they proceed
that there really aren't that many
benefits even though they would be able
to get credit from the back yeah please
perhaps four major droughts that boost
your crops ten right well I did show you
that actually that's some pretty it's an
interesting point to be able to
incorporate into the first draft of the
paper which I didn't do so that's
interesting I did show the figure I
think of two hundred and forty days of
decomposition so I could actually go
back see those studies that went that
far to see what the soil enrichment
factor would be I'm gonna try to
remember that cuz that's actually pretty
good yeah thank you thanks a lot very
interesting certainty composition
nutrient recycling component it sounded
like you are sort of targeting having
nutrient availability when the next crop
was planted I have two questions about
that one is would you want that actually
to be more at the time when the major
nutrient is no that would be hard to
court a suppose I mean look on do it
would just be a longer time to grow the
crank just say oh maybe grow a little
longer you know looking at that period
of availability of the nutrients having
more of an overlap with uptake of the
suspects subsequently crime the other
kind of half of my question is you know
with the with the moisture
cycle have you thought about that
affecting all the processes you know the
growth in the decomposition like were
these crops planted during that early
year I assume they were give me planted
during the drive the dry period so how
would that affect well just I guess the
basic question is just work with the
studies you're looking at where they all
come across all planted during that Wow
right right right
um no that's something also that I could
I could look at sort of shore up make
stronger the the my case and in the
paper that's actually pretty important I
need to see when these were planted see
in fact if they're actually during the
real dry period yeah it makes sense
better look at that I'm gonna write
these down mentally I guess jeez
was there one please yeah again really
the you kind of alluded to the fact that
that you might want to combine the pearl
millet with like um so why why did you
not I mean in the end you didn't come
back to that but would that make sense
even if you follow one with soybean and
maybe my yeah well I mean I probably
should have not just here but also in
the paper expanded on that paper was
already it's probably too long this also
in time constraints and everything but
there's no question apparently the
permit doesn't release enough nitrogen
in some cases it gets sequestered in the
biomass during decomposition something
so combining it with the Sun hemp would
be an excellent idea because the papers
I've seen says it works I mean first of
all that's the first thing the second
thing is that Sun him is used I know
personally a couple of different farmers
they use it but they only use it once in
a while and it's just for breaking
nematode cycles
basically is what it is but uh it would
definitely I think you'd have to because
you know adding what is it a hundred and
twenty kilograms of nitrogen per hectare
you can avoid that maybe putting in the
sent out so I'm gonna try to expand on
that too if I can maybe cut something
out of the paper and include a section
on intercropping I think it would make
my case a little bit strong
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu